the new lady director of whatever The
Next Star Wars movie is going to be just
gave a talk I guess she was being
interviewed by John Stewart at a panel
called women in the world and she said
that her goal for the next Star Wars
movie is to make a really entertaining
and beautiful movie that everyone's
going to enjoy just kidding what she
said was her goal is to make men feel
uncomfortable what is the balance of
activating a force for change but also
trying
to permeate that patriarchy that power
structure and is that a part of the
calculation of your art as well and and
what's been the reaction to that oh
absolutely um I like to make men
uncomfortable I enjoy making men
[Applause]
uncomfortable not you just just not
taken
Tak but um you know it is important to
be able to look into the eyes of a man
and say I am here and recognize that and
recognize that I am working to bring
something that makes you uncomfortable
and it should make you uncomfortable
because you need to change your attitude
and it's only when you're uncomfortable
when you're Shifty when you have to have
difficult conversations that you will
perhaps look at yourself in the mirror
and not like the
reflection so this clip is from some
years ago this lady's name is charmine
oid chinoi and it's coming to the
Forefront now because she's directing
whatever The Next Star Wars movie is and
everyone is rightly concluding from this
that The Next Star Wars movie is going
to be terrible that's been true of
pretty much all the Disney Star Wars
movies there was that one exception what
was it Rogue one I think was okay but
the rest of them have been just
absolutely unbearably bad and the next
one is probably going to be even worse
wor but everyone's just making fun of
her and saying she's a crazy feminist
and she's going to ruin Star Wars which
was ruined many years
ago she does have a point she does have
a point she says I want to make men
uncomfortable men need to feel
uncomfortable and I think that's true
not in the way that she intends it but I
think it's true she thinks that men are
uncomfortable because they've never
never given their power away to women
men are uncom un fortable because
they've never accepted feminism men are
uncomfortable because they're living as
the beneficiaries of the patriarchy
that's all fake news that's all
completely ridiculous the opposite is
true and and that is why men need to
feel uncomfortable men feel discomfort
wielding
power this goes all the way back to to
Chapter 3 of The Book of Genesis when
Adam and Eve sin and God tells them what
their punishment is going to be and
their punishment is in in a way a
blessing because God is equipping man
and woman to live in the Fallen World
he's preparing them for that and he says
to Eve he says to the woman your desire
will be for your man but he shall rule
over
you men contrary to what feminists think
don't actually want to lure over women
they don't want to they don't want to be
knuckle dragging you know screaming
barking orders everywhere making every
single decision just just uh bossing
everyone around that's not what men
actually want do you know what men
actually want men want to sit on the
couch and eat potato chips and be left
alone that's that is what men would do
if we had our
brothers it is a total lie of feminism
that we want to be just stomping around
barking orders at at everybody that's
not what men want to do we don't want to
make every decision we don't want to
have all the responsibility we don't
want the weight of a household and a
family on our shoulders we just kind of
want to be left alone that's our that's
our at least base appetite to be
resisted what we have to do what we are
called to rise up to do is be
responsible and make decisions and take
take
accountability and and that's what men
need to do now men part of the reason
that we have a lot of social dysfunction
is because men won't act like
men men feel uncomfortable acting like
men so we seed every responsibility to
women so so we act like women so in some
cases we chop ourselves up and try to
pretend to be
women that's not good do you do you
really think that the problems the
social problems of America in the year
of Our Lord
2024 are that men are too masculine men
are are are too manly these days are you
kidding me give me a
break if social problems have increased
over the last 50 years as I think we
would all have to agree they
have over that period have men become
more manly or less manly have men become
more patriarchal or less patriarchal
have men become more feminist or less
feminist the answers are very very clear
I totally agree with what's her face
charmine oide
chinoi men need to be made to feel
uncomfortable and the thing that makes
men most uncomfortable these days is
acting like men and taking
responsibility and wielding the just
power with which we have been entrusted
for most of
History we feel less comfortable with
that than ever and to quote Don Corleone
from a good movie unlike some of these
bad movies that have been coming at from
a good movie tells Johnny fontain what
do I what do I do I don't know what to
do Godfather I you can act like a man
it's a matter with you right now go to
express.com Michel n show let me ask you
something what if there were someone out
there who kept a log of every single
thing you did every minute of the day I
think that would be pretty creepy well
what if I told you that's exactly what
happens every time you go online your
internet provider is allowed to store
logs of every website you've ever
visited and can legally sell these data
to anyone that is why I love expressvpn
expressvpn routes your internet
connection through their secure servers
so your internet provider cannot see or
log what you do online many of you might
be wondering well if I'm writing all my
data through a VPN then doesn't that
just mean that the VPN can see what I'm
doing and log that data instead first of
all I would say it's those data because
data are plural but second of all you're
right to think that many vpns claim to
have a no logs policy but they've been
caught logging expressvpn is the only
VPN I trust because they use trusted
server technology this makes it
impossible for their VPN servers to
store any data including logs of any
expressvpn customer you don't have to
take my word for it expressvpn's word
for it either expressvpn is so confident
in their they no logs claim they even
had one of the biggest Assurance firms
PwC audit their technology stop letting
people keep logs of what you do online
expressvpn.com meln show get three extra
months for free
expressvpn.com
Michels show to learn more you got two
people ahead ofis I guess three people
ahead of Chris Christie you got VI
ramaswami but but VI and Chris
Christie's poll numbers are still
relatively low there are two people who
are a little further up even though
they're still far behind Trump that
would be Ronda santis and Nikki Haley or
now we might have to reverse that
because For the first time in a national
poll Nikki Haley has overtaken Ronda
sandz I said yesterday on the show that
for the first time in the RCP average
you had uh the the candidates looking
like they were tied for
second but now I said when when is one
of them going to to overtake the other
one well now you got out of 538 which is
a pretty respectable poll you now have
Nikki Haley as the second place
candidate there is a very real
possibility of a Nikki Haley nomination
and nobody believes this going back to
when she announced her candidacy
everyone wrote her off and laughed at
her and you know I hate to say I told
you so but some of us said hey hey hey
even if you don't like Nikki Haley even
if you think she's too um moderate or
something this is a an extraordinarily
talented politician who was able to
navigate very difficult Waters and and
appeal to The Establishment to the coch
network to the moderates to the
centrists to Center left and to appeal
to Trump supporters she was a not only a
successful member of the Trump
Administration she was a particularly
popular member when she was the UN
Ambassador and when she left Trump gave
her a little a little short of a ticker
tape parade okay but they had a big
meeting lots of cameras Oh Nikki has
been great then Nikki turned on Trump
then she supported Trump again then she
turned on Trump and she's just navigated
the waters very very well don't forget
Trump is being indicted the libs are
going to do everything everything that
they possibly can to keep them off the
ballot totally unprecedented actions
that they've been doing since 2015
2016 using the federal government to spy
on his campaign trying to undermine his
entire Administration with bogus charges
cooked up by the FBI and the Democrats
impeaching him twice doesn't work then
accusing him of insurrection based on
nothing then throwing him off the using
a court to throw him off the ballot
using a secretary of state to throw him
off the ballot doing their very level
best to defend democracy by preventing
people from voting for the most popular
candidate they'll do anything they've
got they've got four indictments now you
know the only thing they've got left
after that is assassination and I don't
put it past them so the number two
person might matter because there is a
world even if Trump is the most popular
candidate and everybody in the world
wants to vote for him there is a world
in which the political order just does
not let him be the nominee which is why
the number two thing matters and could
be Nicki man what a great clip that was
now hold up ring that Bell subscribe to
the mic
YouTube channel see you next time